a protecting group prevents a particular
functional group from reacting in this
lesson we're going to go over some
strategy of using protecting groups
we're not going to go through a lot of
mechanisms but we'll look at several
examples of when to use a protecting
group and we'll look at one example of a
good one
I think this topic is best explained
with examples so let's just dive right
in say that we want to carry out the
following synthesis we want to convert
this ethyl ester into this tertiary
alcohol over here we have an aldehyde on
the molecule and we want that to remain
as an aldehyde throughout the course of
the reaction
first let's devise our general reaction
sequence that'll allow us to perform
this reaction and get our tertiary
alcohol now that we're focusing on just
this piece of the molecule we can see
that we need the OE T group to leave we
also need to add in two ethyl groups and
a great way to add in a carbon
nucleophile to add an alkyl group into a
molecule is by using a grignard reagent
esters actually will smoothly react with
two equivalents of the grignard reagent
and then a protonation step will give us
this alcohol here I'll draw out the
intermediate after the first equivalent
of grignard reagent attacks in case
you're a little unfamiliar with this
reaction or don't remember it so the
grignard nucleophile attacks here that
pushes the electrons up onto oxygen
giving this tetrahedral intermediate and
then these electrons can push down
kicking out the ethoxide leaving group
that gives a ketone which is attacked a
second time by the grignard reagent okay
great so what's the problem with
applying that reaction to this
transformation here well the problem is
that the ethyl ester over here is not
the most reactive part of the molecule
we have this aldehyde and this aldehyde
is prone to attack it's even more
reactive than the ester the ester has
resonance from the lone pair on this
oxygen that's actually stabilizing this
functional group the aldehyde doesn't
have a group over here just a little
small hydrogen atom and so it's not very
sterically hindered it doesn't have this
stabilizing resonance so actually our
aldehyde will want to react first and
it'll do so more readily than our ester
so here's our complication drawn out
we're doomed to get mixtures of the
ethyl group adding in over here and some
over here our solution is to use a
protecting group to mask this aldehyde
there are three criteria for a
protecting group it must be easy to put
on then it must be unreactive toward all
the conditions that the molecule needs
to go through so every reaction that you
put it on for it has to be compatible
with it and then in the end it should be
easy to remove for this problem we can
use an acetal protecting group let's
check out our synthesis now the fact
that the aldehyde is much more reactive
than the ester doesn't do our synthesis
it's actually an advantage for
introducing the protecting group if we
treat this molecule with this dial
ethylene glycol in the presence of acid
this group is more reactive so it will
react to form an acetal protecting group
and the ester will stay in this form the
acetal is a base stable protecting group
that is removed in acid so we put it on
using acid then we can remove it by
acidic hydrolysis since it's based
stable we can now apply these conditions
above and the acidic conditions of our
workup might just be enough to remove
this protecting group too so in this
first step the reaction happens where we
add in our ethyl group twice and then
when we're protonating this we might be
able to just heat it up and remove our
protecting group at the same time let's
call this target molecule one and we
form that by the
sequence using the acetal protecting
group let's check out another example in
this example we're also forming an
alcohol and we're reacting this piece of
the molecule this maps on over here and
we're adding a new alcohol and a phenyl
group it might benefit us to think about
where we're breaking this molecule do a
little retrosynthesis to see the pieces
that we might have to put together to
actually form this so over here we have
one two three four carbon atoms so if we
go one two three four we'll see that we
need to cleave the molecule here well
when I see a bromide I think grignard
reagent let's take a moment to look at
sentence the hypothetical electrophiles
and nucleophiles that we would use to
form this target molecule 2 over on this
side we were talking about forming a
grignard from this bromide so this would
be our nucleophilic piece now let's
consider what this side would look like
this fragment would have to be our
electrophile with some positive
character on this carbon but a thing
that we can think about is when we have
an OHA up next to a carbo cation what
would that look like if the oxygen
donated in its electrons and formed a
bond the reagent that we would use would
be this Epoque side and grignard 'he's
very smoothly open at the least
sterically hindered side of the Epoque
side so we'd expect this to attach over
here just like we want so that's awesome
we have a synthetic route in mind now so
what's the problem here let's imagine we
take this compound treat it with
magnesium metal and make a grignard so
we might imagine this grignard starts to
form but this is actually a
self-destructing grignard there's an
acidic group right here so before this
grignard could ever attack and open an
epoxy forming a carbon-carbon bond it
will instead react with
reacted molecule of starting material
deprotonating this alcohol here and
destroying the grignard before it can
even do its job so our synthesis must
incorporate a protecting group for the
alcohol
this time we can protect our alcohol
with this silicon group chlorine is
going to act as a leaving group here and
we'll put this group onto the molecule
this group is tert-butyl dimethyl shylo
chloride and is sometimes abbreviated
tbdms chloride or more commonly TBS
chloride so we get this whole big group
on here the group is based stable the
base in this reaction is an amine base
so it just takes that proton off after
the TBS group is on the alcohol and a
commonly used base in this reaction is a
Mitte soul now we don't usually draw
this whole group on here let me just
show you how we would abbreviate this
structure now that this oxygen contains
a base stable protecting group we can go
ahead and form a grignard here and
attack this Epoque side now if this
workup is acidic that might knock off
our TB s group right then and so we
might kick off the TB s and free up our
alcohol however we're gonna say it did
not here and i want to show you the
standard conditions for removing a TB s
group which is a fluoride compound
called t bath this is a fluoride salt
tetra butyl ammonium fluoride and it
looks like this so the f minus of t bath
comes in attack set silicon forming a
complex and then this group is removed
from the molecule let's just summarize
how this met the three criteria of a
protecting group this was pretty easy to
put on we just needed this compound here
in the presence of a base probably a mid
acyl and we were able to put the silicon
group onto our oxygen it was stable when
we formed a grignard over here and use
that to open this up oxide and then it
was easily removed with t bath
so far in this lesson we looked at
protecting groups for aldehydes and
ketones the asset al is a good one we
also looked at how to protect an alcohol
from deprotonation by nucleophiles and
looked at the TBS group another group
that we commonly need to protect is
amines so let's take this third example
we're looking at the alkylation of this
Oh H group so we're adding a methyl or a
ch3 here and we're leaving this nitrogen
unreacted first let's just ignore the
amine over here and look at what we
would need to use to turn this alcohol
into this methyl group
we can use a reaction called the
Williamson ether synthesis where we
first deprotonate this hydrogen atom
here and then we alkylate with something
like iota methane a great base to use
for this reaction is sodium hydride this
will deep protonate our alcohol
completely forming an alkoxide and as a
byproduct produces hydrogen gas which
bubbles out of your reaction then in a
second stage of this reaction in the
same flask we can treat this with methyl
iodide and that'll alkylate our oxygen
over here giving the methyl ether so
what's the problem with having the
nitrogen on there
well amines are great nucleophiles so in
the presence of iota methane the
nitrogen would be more likely to attack
becoming alkylated than the O H group
but over here we talked about
deprotonating this so maybe we could
just deprotonate with sodium hydride and
then we'd have an alkoxide which is nice
and nucleophilic and maybe we could
solve our problem that way let's see
what would happen if we tried that well
certainly our alkoxide wants to react
with the methyl iodide more so this
would attack displacing iodine once we
form this we actually still have a
nucleophilic nitrogen in the molecule
and now we don't have our alkoxide to be
the better nucleophile this is going to
go ahead and alkyl a kicking off the
iodine and so we're still going to get
Mik
stirrers of alkylation at the oxygen and
at the nitrogen and so we won't be able
to cleanly perform this synthesis where
the nitrogen is unreacted so what should
we do
Hugh guess that we need to protect our
amine amines are more nucleophilic than
alcohols not the deprotonated alkoxide
but more so than the alcohol itself so
we can capitalize on the nucleophilicity
of nitrogen to introduce our protecting
group this protecting group is died
tert-butyl died carbamate it's an
anhydride but also a carbonate because
of all of these oxygens and the nitrogen
is going to attack at this carbonyl
kicking off all of this group
fortunately just like that big TBS group
we have an abbreviation for this one as
well we call this BOC anhydride and we
write the abbreviation like this so the
BOC is representing this part of the
molecule so we have two of them and an
oxygen in the middle nitrogen attacks
here forms a tetrahedral intermediate we
kick off the rest of the molecule and we
get this structure here it is with our
abbreviation and let me draw it out
below now the nitrogen is a carbamate
functional group that's what it is when
it has the nitrogen carbonyl oxygen like
an amide this nitrogen has lots of
resonance with this carbonyl thus the
lone pairs that would have attacked
iodoethane in that alkylation step are
now tied up in resonance making the
nitrogen less reactive it's protected
because it is not as nucleophilic
anymore now let's deprotonate our
alcohol and alkylate now our bak group
was stable during these basic alkylation
conditions notice it has a carbonyl so
some nucleophiles could mess with the
BOC group maybe grignard --zz and things
like that but under these alkylation
conditions it's just fine
the BOC group is most commonly removed
under acidic conditions and the
preferred acid for this reaction is
trifluoroacetic acid or TFA and if we
call
this compound target molecule three
that's what we get from this deep
protection under acidic conditions this
group is removed as a tert-butyl cation
and so sometimes there's problems with
alkylating other groups with that cation
that's in solution but there are other
additives to work around this organic
chemistry org has some nice tables on
protecting groups so I'll put a link to
that in the video description thanks for
watching and have a great day KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel